[Musique]
depuis le début ça a été une expérience
où j'ai dû travailler beaucoup
j'ai commencé très jeune et c'est pas
toujours facile comprendre que c'est pas
pour jouer ou s'amuser même si on la
passe très bien
c'est vraiment un travail très sérieux
qui a besoin de la fonctionnalité du un
comportement complètement
professionnelle alors déjà la
préparation de mon travail de mes études
a été très sérieuse
ça m'a beaucoup marqué depuis le début
après il ya un projet qui a beaucoup
marqué ma carrière s'intéressa et
pouvoir faire une femme avec ce
caractère et parler quand même pas le
bouger comme ex rouges c'est pas des
choses que moi je fais je suis pas comme
ça et ça marqué une génération dans le
petit mexicain surtout et la troisième
je pourrais dire c'est quand j'ai fini
de faire les choix de l'amour j'ai perdu
ma maman et ça a été quelque chose de
très très dur à la fin du feuilleton le
vivre et continue à travailler et
continuer
monserrat que la vida mais robben
j'adore ce personnage j'ai adoré ce
projet c'est une femme tellement subtil
tellement tôt se remet avec du caractère
et racontée dans un feuilleton une femme
qui tombe amoureuse de deux hommes
s'étaient très complexe de ne pas se
faire haïr dans le chemin non alors
c'est un personnage que j'ai beaucoup
adoré et respect c'est salins j'ai
beaucoup aimé le personnage d'un halo
cia qui fait là et la danse aérienne
avec l'étoile c'est quelque chose que je
remercie beaucoup parce que j'ai fait
une acrobatie
le meti lactation des comédiens ça nous
permet de vivre plus de temps je sens
que notre vie est le double parce qu'on
a l'opportunité de vivre nos propres
sentiments et de trouver l'explication
dans les sentiments des autres même si
on sait des choses qu'on n'a même pas
vécu on n'a pas besoin de les vivre pour
savoir se poser dans la situation de
l'autre dans la situation du personnage
alors c'est ça que j'aime le plus
pouvoir ressentir de la compassion pour
mes personnages et leur donner la vérité
dans toutes leurs actions même si des
fois c'est pas des plus corrects il faut
les défendre
et voilà à pouvoir donner au tour du
monde avec mon travail et rentrait dans
les maisons on est un groupe et la
famille qui voit le feuilleton c'est
quelque chose qui me touche le coeur et
qui me donne une raison de 2 pourquoi je
suis ici pourquoi j'essaie de vie et
cette profession
[Musique]
oui ça a été très compliqué par ce
projet parce que hannah l'éthicien avec
tout le temps les ongles rouges et deux
autres non alors chaque fois me changer
le maquillage est la personnification de
chacune
ça nous prenait à peu près une heure et
demie ça a été un projet très long pour
toute l'équipe
c'était très difficile mais j'ai aussi
beaucoup appris à travailler comme ils
font les films de science fiction parce
qu'il y avait de quoi j'étais
complètement dans une chambre verte
il fallait s'imaginer les espaces et
marqué avec du scotch
là où il fallait s'arrêter jusqu'où tu
pouvais arriver leurs règles qui soient
il fallait très très précis alors j'ai
beaucoup aimé apprendre à travailler
comme ça et mais il faut être fort pour
faire des films de personnages de
science fiction parce que c'est très dur
à imaginer à travailler sur ça
[Musique]